♪
(narrator)
It's called the beautiful game
for a reason.
A distinction
accurately painted
by the game's legendary
artist-- Pelé.
Football, or soccer
as it's known in the US,
is the number one sport
in 93 countries.
Most important
is to do, for the--
the foreigners,
for the people who gonna
be there, nice show,
and the-- and they receive
it well, the people there.
(narrator)
And one can link
its worldwide popularity
to its simplicity.
No financial obstacles,
because all you need
is a football.
I think it's the only game
in the world
that brings every
single country together.
Yes, it's one language,
it's football,
but what sport does is,
it brings everyone together.
It gets everyone talking.
(narrator)
From back alleys
and side streets,
to muddy fields
and scorched sand,
it can be played anywhere
by anyone,
boys and girls,
rich and poor.
It's inviting
to all walks of life.
Football now is a sport
which is taken very seriously.
(narrator)
For 3,000 years,
this has been the world's game.
And for many centuries,
every legend started
from the same point.
From Beckham to Pelé
and Sir Bobby Charlton,
their journey began the same
manner as everyone else.
For 3,000 years,
this has been
the world's game.
And for many centuries,
every legend started
from the same point.
Cristiano Ronaldo, star player
for Real Madrid and Portugal,
was molded from the same
humble beginnings.
♪
(thunder cracking)
(camera shutter clicking)
(narrator)
On the fifth of February, 1985,
a baby boy was born
to Maria Dolores
dos Santos Aveiro,
and José Dinis Aveiro.
They were simple people,
making their way through life
as a cook and a gardener
in Santo Antonio, Funchal.
This small town is located
on the island
of Madeira, Portugal,
overlooking the ocean.
Santo Antonio
means Saint Anthony,
and on that day, a saint
was indeed delivered
into the world of football.
Cristiano Ronaldo
dos Santos Aveiro.
Named after his father's
favorite actor,
US President Ronald Reagan,
Ronaldo's early life hardly
resembled a Hollywood movie.
His rag to riches story
begins with a childhood
rooted in severe poverty.
His Catholic family,
like many others in the town,
struggled to survive.
Food and shelter
were considered luxuries.
And at Christmastime,
there was rarely any sign
of Santa Claus.
Their house
was a tin-roofed shack
which would often leak
due to the warm
and powerful thunderstorms
that graced the Portugal
coast each summer.
A lot of guys do
come out from,
from poverty,
hard upbringings,
and that's their motivation.
A lot of that is the motivation
that keeps them pushing.
(narrator)
Cristiano was
the youngest child.
Having an elder brother Hugo
and two elder sisters,
Elma and Liliana Catia.
Quarters were tight,
as Ronaldo, his brother,
and two sisters shared one room.
The dirt floor
was their bed.
Crumpled clothing
served as a pillow.
In addition to the financial
hardships of this family,
he also found it hard
to make friends his own age.
He was a lonely boy,
and his only
companion
became a tattered football
he found in an alleyway.
He would take the ball
to a nearby wall,
and there, between
the cement and stone,
he practiced.
He'd spend every waking hour
with his friend,
skipping meals,
and sometimes school.
(man)
What inspired you
to take up soccer?
to start playing?
Well, that one is a tough
question, good question.
(audience laughing)
Hmm... I don't know
why I had football.
Maybe because
the sports that I,
since when I was a kid,
it's what, um...
made me motivation.
Maybe because
of my brother,
my father, my cousins.
Because they all
play football.
(narrator)
Ronaldo's childhood mirrored
that of another
football great,
Edison Arantes
do Nascimento.
You probably know him
simply as Pelé.
Before becoming a three-time
champion at the World Cup,
and scoring over 1,300 goals,
Pelé's career started
with an old sock
stuffed with rags.
His father, a minor league
footballer, taught Pelé.
And with his unmatched
dedication, he flourished.
Pelé would become the youngest
player ever to win the World Cup
at just 17 years old,
scoring six goals for Brazil.
Love!
(crowd)
(narrator)
And for Ronaldo,
much like Pelé,
if it wasn't about football,
it was a nuisance.
Football was his life.
He molded his skills
playing against everyone
and anyone,
young and old.
Without application,
your talent
doesn't mean anything.
You've got to have the two.
Application
without talent
is difficult, but you can
still maybe get by.
Um, talent without
no application,
you've got no chance.
(narrator)
At the age of eight,
Ronaldo joined amateur
local team Andorinha.
At that age,
this young child was a far cry
from the muscled athlete
that commands the pitch today.
And even though
he was skinnier
and less developed
than his competition,
Ronaldo's talents
were recognized immediately.
Ronaldo, he started off
at a really young age.
I mean, you know, like we all
do when we're starting football.
And then when you get to sort of
an age of 10, 11, 12 years old,
you'll then start finding
that these clubs will be,
and professional clubs,
will be looking at you
to see whether they can
actually move you forward.
(narrator)
Ronaldo's skills
were creating
a great deal of buzz.
Smaller football clubs in Spain,
Portugal, and England
are always on the lookout
for their next star,
and the competition
is tough.
Having the ability to
occasionally strike the ball
into the goal is not enough
to get you noticed.
The first thing
we look for in any player
is what natural ability
he's got.
Now, it's not
what we can coach him,
it's what has he got
that he shows us?
What does he bring to us?
And then after that,
you know,
does he got
a love for the game,
does he love training,
does he love coaching?
Has he got a passion
for the game?
And is he full
of enthusiasm?
But first and foremost
is his own natural ability.
(narrator)
However, this was not a problem
for the young Ronaldo.
At just 12 years of age,
he moved 600 miles
from his poor small town
to the city of Lisbon
where he had
an offer from Sporting.
He had the opportunity then
to move to a sizeable,
very big club in Portugal,
which then allowed him
with his family
to progress
and push him forward.
That's where you need
the support to actually
move forward with your career.
(narrator)
Though he continued
to turn heads,
the transition
was not easy for Cristiano.
It's hard now
to imagine this player
ever had a problem
with popularity.
But way before the fancy cars,
expensive clothes,
and supermodel girlfriends,
Ronaldo was alone.
Miles from home,
in a strange city,
school was a struggle,
and his only redemption
came on the pitch.
Constantly bullied by classmates
for his Madeirine accent,
and forced to be alone,
he lost faith in his education
and teachers.
It reached
a boiling point at 14
when Ronaldo threw a chair
at an instructor.
He was expelled.
This was not an issue
in his mother's eyes.
As his biggest ally,
Ronaldo's mother rallied
around her youngest son.
She supported his aspiring
football career with gusto.
And with his family's
backing,
Ronaldo continued
his meteoric rise
into the upper echelons
of the beautiful game.
That's what it's all about,
it's dedication, keep working.
You haven't got to be
too old or too young,
just keep working
at your physique.
We've constantly got to
be trying to bring players
into the first team squad,
so the pressure's there
every year
to sort of make sure
that the quality's good enough.
(narrator)
But the next year,
Ronaldo was dealt
another difficult card.
He was diagnosed
with a racing-heart
condition,
(man)
Surgical ablation which
is relatively new
from a minimally invasive
standpoint
involves also making burn
lesions on the outside
of the heart
and also getting rid
of that left atrial appendage,
which is the little portion
of the heart where
the clot forms
that then often can fire off
to the body.
(narrator)
Thankfully for us,
his mother opted
to let Ronaldo
have the operation,
and the rest, as they say,
is history.
♪
Better than new,
the stars aligned
for the young phenomenon
on August 12, 2003.
Seventeen years old
and already a prime target
among football scouts,
Cristiano Ronaldo and Sporting
faced off against football giant
Manchester United.
Old Trafford's a far cry
from the dirt pitches
of Madeira, Portugal,
and The Red Devils
are football icons.
Undaunted in front of
the legendary coach
Sir Alex Ferguson,
and giving the performance
of a lifetime,
Sporting won 3-1.
And Ronaldo was the only thing
that anyone could talk about.
Manchester United was,
for me, I think
that was his stepping-stone
to move his career
much more forward.
Ferguson saw something
there in a player
that really could progress
and become something big.
And of course we all know
today, that's what was the case.
(narrator)
Ironically, it wasn't
the assistant coaches
who had the idea to sign Ronaldo
to Manchester United.
It was the players.
On the way home from the match,
a few of his would-be teammates
convinced Ferguson
that Ronaldo should be
on their side.
But other clubs
had taken notice
of the teenage phenomenon.
Ronaldo's path
to Manchester United
was almost derailed
by Arsenal's manager
Arsene Wegner.
In fact, Ronaldo was so close
to signing with the Gunners,
Wegner gave Ronaldo
his own number 9 jersey.
But Ferguson was able to snatch
the Portuguese star.
Remember, he came in
as a 17-year-old lad
and really developed himself
here as a great footballer,
so I think we
are proud of that.
(narrator)
Never one to mince his words,
Ferguson was a visionary
who led one of the world's
best football clubs
for over two decades.
He brought home 38 trophies,
including 13 Premier
League Titles.
The training session,
intensity, expectation,
the level of concentration
will always manifest itself
in a Saturday.
He's had
a amazing career, um...
One that, you know,
many managers look at
and want to achieve
what he has achieved.
(David Beckham)
I owe him a lot
as a manager for the way
he brought me
into Manchester United,
and then he groomed me
into a player
that went on
to win 19 trophies.
(narrator)
Upon his arrival,
it was requested that Ronaldo
wear a special jersey.
Cristiano Ronaldo would don
the heavily weighted
number 7.
And as time would tell,
he would immortalize it.
(Paul Cann)
So, you're looking
for a father figure
to look after you
and take you under your wings,
and you as a player
would need to trust
that particular person.
And that's obviously
what happened.
And when you've got a manager
like Sir Alex Ferguson
and the background staff,
and the players of course,
help him to settle,
that would allow him
then to
freely play his football.
(narrator)
Ronaldo signed with United
for a transfer fee
of an extraordinary
15 million Euros.
You've got a manager that's
been there for 20-odd years
that had won pretty much,
well, everything in the game.
Unbelievable success record.
(translator)
I think it's just
the way I play.
Ever since I was
a youngster in Madeira,
I've always been a player
that enjoyed
taking someone
on one-on-one.
It's in my nature,
and I've always done this.
He's speedy with the ball,
either foot,
manipulating it,
making decisions
in and outside
of fullback,
planning and moving into
position and done at speed.
And everything
was done at great speed.
And I think that was the thing
that made me sit up.
(narrator)
Ronaldo wasn't the first
young football star
to join Manchester
and wear the number seven.
David Beckham began his career
with the Red Devils
at the age of just 17.
Beckham was to quickly
fulfill his potential
as one of the world's best,
winning six league titles
and two FA cups
at the hallowed
grounds of Old Trafford.
He always had
a lovely smile, you know,
and he always presents
himself well,
but as a young kid, when I
got him at 12 years of age,
his great desire was to be
the best footballer.
He was a fantastic trainer,
practiced all the time.
And at nighttime, he'd
come back with the schoolboys
and practice with them.
(narrator)
Much like Ronaldo,
Beckham has played the role
of hero and villain.
In a 1998 World Cup second-round
match against Argentina,
Beckham, after being fouled,
kicked midfielder
Diego Simeone in the calf.
Beckham was given a red card
and England was eliminated.
Beckham was blamed
for the defeat,
and he and his family
received death threats.
He was demonized
in the media.
Crazed fans hung and burned
an effigy of him outside a pub.
You'd much rather
have your own fans--
you do expect a lot of stick
from opposition fans,
but you'd much rather
have your own fans with you
than against you.
And fans help much more
when you're having a bad time.
It's easy to cheer,
to cheer your team
when you're doing well,
but when you're having
a bit of a rough time,
you need your fans
to get through it.
Beckham's the link,
if you like,
with these players
in the countries
then there's a good chance
that he may come over, Ronaldo,
to participate
in the US League, the MLS.
And if he does, I certainly
think that that would be
a huge coup for the US.
I'm excited about bringing
the team and being part
of the MLS and continuing
to be a part of the MLS.
(narrator)
Cristiano Ronaldo's
United career
proved to be successful
from the get-go.
In his first season,
Ronaldo scored the opening goal
in United's 3-0 FA Cup final
victory over Millwall.
The first ever
Portuguese footballer
to play for Manchester United,
Cristiano Ronaldo
had not only arrived,
but also became
Player of the Year.
Ronaldo is heralded
as a master striker.
He plays an attacking role
better than anyone,
often referred to as
"The Sultan of the Step-over,"
showing unmatched skill
with both feet
and the ability
to beat players one-on-one
unparalleled in the rest
of the game.
The whole game
of the football has changed.
It's completely changed.
You know, you've got
all this different dietician-y
type of food that you
have to eat now,
and they monitor
your heart rate,
your pulse rate,
everything.
(narrator)
His height, strength,
and vertical leap
give him an edge
in aerial challenges,
and the majority of his goals
are, in fact, headers.
I think he's been a fantastic
advert for the game.
His scoring record,
ratio to games played,
is second to none.
Ronaldo, tremendous player.
One of the best players
in the world,
if not the best
goal-scorer in the world.
And when he scores goals...
left foot, right foot,
he can head a ball,
he can take people on,
his step-overs.
(narrator)
At the height of his success
at Manchester United
in 2005,
Ronaldo was dealt
a significant blow.
His father passed away.
Jose died due to a chronic
liver condition
brought on by years of
struggling against alcoholism.
He was only 52 years old.
Ronaldo, only 20 at the time,
was hit hard by the loss.
But, as at every moment
of hardship in his life,
Ronaldo's mother Maria
was there for him.
She's been an unwavering pillar
of support and love in his life,
and he's said often
that he would not be
where he is today
without his mother.
Ronaldo still carries
a lingering heartache
for his father's passing,
as he never got to share
any of his success
with his father.
To this day he never forgets
how his dad was instrumental
in getting him started
in this sport.
Many think him
too much of a peacock,
preening and flashy,
concerned completely
with his image.
He doesn't make it easy,
turning many viewers off
with his arrogance
and over-confidence.
Where I think
he's toned it down, I think,
by hanging with models
and other sports stars
that are on the kind
of salary that he's on,
um, it has taught him a lot
for how to, you know,
look good,
but keep it minimum,
which he's never done well.
He loves the bling-bling,
he loves the solid tan.
But I think he's learned a lot
and he's matured a lot.
And that's seen
through his fashion
and his clothing choices.
The guy
is a total professional.
What he does in his own time
is up to him, I mean, that's--
He is obviously,
I think he gives quite
a good image
for a footballer.
(narrator)
Other fans think he dives
without the slightest
contact,
and are annoyed that a player
as well built as Ronaldo
would take
to the turf so easily.
Ronaldo's penchant
for persuading referees
was highlighted in a 2006
World Cup match against England.
Wayne Rooney,
a Manchester United teammate,
was whistled for stamping
on a Portugal defender.
Ronaldo immediately started
to plead his case to the ref
and Rooney shoved him.
Rooney was given
the red card.
And as he left the pitch,
cameras caught Ronaldo winking
at his teammate.
Portugal may have won
the quarterfinal match,
but Ronaldo didn't win many fans
in the process.
(woman)
Somebody's probably
gonna break your legs,
in a--
in a nasty tackle.
Could be Rooney,
you never know.
You think?
He's got, he's got to get you
back for one, doesn't he?
(narrator)
Rumors of turmoil
began to spread
that tension between
Ronaldo and Rooney
following
the now infamous wink
would be too much for
Manchester United to overcome.
Ronaldo was taking the brunt
of the blame.
CR7, as he was known,
was becoming football's
greatest villain.
(narrator)
Soon, reports surfaced
that Ronaldo wanted to transfer,
and Real Madrid
was his chosen team.
He had to get there by going
through Manchester United,
and the progression
that he made through that club
enabled him then
to move forward
into a Real Madrid team
that today is huge.
And that's the club
that he wanted to go to.
His family, I think, wanted him
to go to that club, as well.
His mother, and he was
in a situation
where he couldn't say no.
(narrator)
The press told stories
of a torn locker room,
and the team's chemistry
in jeopardy.
No one could blame
Ronaldo if he left.
He could've blamed it on the fan
reaction, the resentment.
He had a built-in excuse
in that the World Cup incident
was too much to overcome.
But Cristiano Ronaldo
rarely takes the easy route.
(translator)
There are things in life
that deserve no comment.
This is one more of those
that will receive no comment
on my part,
for obvious reasons.
I've always respected all
my coaches everywhere I've been,
and I always keep
the positive things.
So I always try to learn
something new from them.
To talk about people
that speak ill of me,
well, it's not something
that I'm used to.
People talk ill of me,
especially in Portugal.
But I don't spit into the plate
that I eat from.
Does he understand that?
Is that correct?
I just try to keep
to the positive things.
If you watch the players,
the first thing they want
to do at the end
of the game is go across
to their own supporters
and thank them.
But on the other hand,
you've got other clubs where,
if things aren't
working out, then the fans
can turn on you very quick.
And that's why he's got
as far as he has done today,
by playing for Real Madrid,
because of his arrogance,
his professionalism.
(narrator)
Ronaldo met manager
Sir Alex Ferguson
for dinner in Portugal
to discuss the situation.
Sir Alex is no stranger
to handling football superstars,
and convinced the young
striker to stay.
A five-year extension
was inked, and Ronaldo became
the highest paid player
in the team's history.
They are more or less
film stars, movie stars.
The amount of money that's
poured into the game now has--
has risen their status
massively.
(narrator)
On the heels of his
new five-year deal,
Ronaldo carried the Red Devils
to its second of what would be
three straight English
Premier League championships,
as well as taking home the UEFA
Champions League trophy.
I just try to do
my best all the time,
season by season.
I try to, to be better,
better player, better person.
I try to learn myself
all the time.
And, um, I have opportunity
to score goals and I score.
(narrator)
One of the gems
of Ferguson's legendary career
was keeping Ronaldo
in a United uniform
for as long as he did.
Ferguson was known
for cultivating talent
as well as clashing with it.
Tensions between Ferguson
and David Beckham
boiled over in 2003,
when following a loss
to Arsenal in the FA cup,
Ferguson kicked a boot
at David Beckham,
resulting in the Englishman
getting stitches above his eye.
David did not have
two stitches put in his head,
he had no stitches.
So it was a graze, and he's
dealt with, with a doctor,
there's no problem,
and we move on.
(narrator)
And similar to Beckham,
Ronaldo eventually
was granted his request
to transfer to Real Madrid
in 2009.
The £80 million transfer fee
was a record at that time.
I think we have a player
in the top of his game.
We have a player
that left Portugal
with an incredible talent,
transformed
that incredible talent
in his time in Manchester.
And now knowing
a certain coach,
I think he achieved
his maximum level.
He's fabulous player.
And normally this kind
of players, they make,
uh, they can
make a difference.
(narrator)
That's until current teammate
Gareth Bale joined Madrid
transferring over
from Tottenham
in the Barclay's
Premier League.
Our guys
is doing amazing.
He start a little bit...
As I say, like with some
injuries, some small problems,
it's normal because
he didn't do the preseason,
and after what's happened
with him,
a lot
of pressure, you know.
It's hard, but I think
now he's in a good way.
He helps out a lot,
he's integrate more in the team.
People like him,
like the supporters
and the players
around him.
I think it's a--
it's a fantastic player,
and I wish that he can
help us win trophies.
Cristiano Ronaldo is, for me,
the best player in the world.
I think he's a massive factor.
Why I wanted
to come here as well.
I think the team is full
of world-class players
and there comes
no better than him.
And, uh, it will obviously
be an honor.
(narrator)
At first, everyone wondered
if these two could play
together in harmony.
It's not difficult for him,
but I understand.
If you, if you speak
with him, you can see
that he's very
exciting to play,
to help the team, to getting
better and better.
But it's better
to leave him alone.
Don't make him pressure,
do pressure to another players.
Leave him alone.
Because I'm sure 100%
that he's gonna
do well for the club.
He gonna help us a lot
because he's a fantastic player.
He's a fantastic boy,
and he always want to learn.
And this is
the most important.
(narrator)
Now, after the first season,
the combination
of Ronaldo and Bale
is proving to be deadly
for any opposing team.
Cristiano Ronaldo soon
became a worldwide phenomenon.
He's the most Google-searched
athlete across the globe.
Millions idolize him,
and just as many hate him.
He is the ultimate polarizing
figure in sports.
I think that Ronaldo coming
from a very poor background
has indeed had an effect
on his career
and on his
business decisions.
I think that he has
had to claw his way up
and take every opportunity
that's given to him,
but equally, so too
have other people
that have come
from much better-off
backgrounds.
But I think he's been
very clever in the way
that he's used
his perhaps skills
that he learned at a young age
to his advantage today.
(narrator)
Although much of Ronaldo's skill
was shaped and molded
with his fiery determination
and will and pure hard work,
one wonders if this
otherworldly talent
got an assist from destiny.
Born on February 5th, 1985,
under the Aquarian sun
and Leo moon,
the stars lit
the path for Ronaldo,
equipping him with
the relentless passion
to be great.
Aquarians are brilliant
communicators.
They work well with the media,
so they're an absolute gift
to any corporate organization
trying to push their wares.
And Ronaldo has made
many endorsements
for most products
you can think of.
(narrator)
Those born with an Aquarian sun
can be enchanting
and often unhinged.
The placement of Mars could tell
us that little Cristiano Ronaldo
would become a man of action,
a self-sufficient born leader.
It seems even the Cosmos
has made it their goal
to see Ronaldo
armed with all the traits
of a superior
athletic force.
Ronaldo is a really
typical Aquarian.
He just loves the limelight.
And Ronaldo will always
want to succeed.
He'll always want to be
number one, the best.
And if money comes with it,
well, money comes with it.
Aquarians can take it
or leave it with money.
But when money really
comes to an Aquarian,
it either comes big time,
or nothing at all.
In Ronaldo's case,
he's made plenty in his life.
(narrator)
But he's not the only one
in his family to gain fame.
Ronaldo's older sister,
Catia Aveiro is a singer
and signed a record deal
in 2013.
Naturally, Ronaldo
has always been her biggest fan
as she used to sing
around the house
when they were younger.
No matter where her career
takes her, Catia knows
her younger brother will always
be there to support her dreams.
As Ronaldo's
legions of fans grew,
so did his critics.
Ronaldo instantly
had a target on his back.
Tabloid magazines
and websites
hounded his every
move off the pitch.
The word to describe
Cristiano Ronaldo... skimpy.
Loves skimpy.
Speedos, I don't get it.
You know, I suppose
if you look that good
you can show it off,
but he shows it off a lot.
(narrator)
Any celebrity knows
that as fame rises,
privacy often falls.
Paparazzi are an issue
for any star,
but for a global
icon like Ronaldo,
it can be impossible to find
a moment's peace.
(man)
Watch out, watch out, watch out!
Yo, you're going the wrong way.
You're going the wrong way.
Back up!
(man #2)
What are you doing here?
- Back up!
- Cristiano!
(shouting)
(narrator)
His home is stalked
by cameramen
and videographers,
often provoking him
with personal questions.
(men shouting)
(man)
How's your baby?!
(narrator)
And Ronaldo has clashed
with a paparazzo on more
than one occasion.
It's hard to blame him
considering how much
they hawk
his every single move.
I think the difference
with the Beckhams
is that they're
a partnership.
There's one of Ronaldo,
there's two Beckhams.
They weren't the people
that arrived on the scene
many years ago.
Ronaldo I think is equally
making that effort,
but he comes from
a very different culture,
a very, very different
way of life.
(narrator)
However, his salary does allow
the striker to outrun
the paps.
The footballer
has some of the fastest
and most expensive cars
on the planet.
Whether he's whipping
by in his Bugatti Veyron,
or cruising in his
Rolls Royce Phantom,
he has spent nearly $5 million
on his treasured car collection.
Cristiano Ronaldo is one of
the highest paid sportsman
in the world, so you can
imagine he's gonna have
one of the best
collections in the world.
I mean, you can start off,
he's got a Bugatti Veyron,
he's got plenty
of Lamborghinis, McLarens,
Ferraris, Bentleys,
pretty much anything
you can imagine,
Cristiano Ronaldo will have.
The lifestyle is fantastic.
There is money,
there are cars,
there are houses,
media exposure.
It's very difficult to live
a life in the limelight,
and that's why I think you see
a lot of the younger stars
sort of failing,
as it would be,
in many aspects of life
by the time they're mid-20's.
He likes to be seen,
he's got a lot of convertibles,
so he'll pop the roof
and people, you know,
he wants people to see him
driving these cars.
And that's part
of his character.
(narrator)
But he doesn't only fill
his own garage.
Ronaldo promised the five-person
training staff of Real Madrid
that if he won
the FIFA Ballon d'Or,
he would buy each of them
a new car of their choice.
In 2013, Ronaldo went home
with the award,
and true to his word,
his training staff
was driving home
in their brand-new cars
soon after.
Cannot expect a better night
than this one ever in my dreams,
so I have to be proud
of my work,
what I did during the year.
And this is gonna
give me motivation
to work more, and dedicate
myself more for the future.
And I hope to be here next year
to try to win the third one.
(narrator)
Throughout his career,
Ronaldo made headlines
on and off the pitch.
Recently, he announced
that there is a junior Ronaldo.
The identity of the mother
has never been released.
The boy,
named Cristiano Ronaldo Jr.
attends every match
with his grandmother.
Ronaldo says he plans to
raise him with religious values
and won't spoil him
even though he's being
raised in immense wealth.
Ronaldo prides himself
on being
a loving and caring dad.
Ronaldo, despite his
gargantuan wealth and success,
is always mindful of where
he came from,
and the hardships he had
to endure to achieve his dreams.
The asphalt alley
and stone well
are never far
from his thoughts.
If you're looking for Ronaldo
on his day off, you probably
won't find him in a local bar.
Odds are he could be at a youth
practice in his native Portugal.
Hello, hello.
We pass, pass, pass, pass,
and we didn't shoot.
One opportunity,
shoot in the net.
I think they play
all in the same place.
They have to make
this space huge.
Try to be fast, try to,
you know, to fake him,
and try to change
acceleration.
Just try to have the ball.
And good control.
Good control.
Good.
(narrator)
Cristiano Ronaldo
has been criticized
for his extravagant spending
and lifestyle.
But without question,
his heart, support,
and generosity
have saved many lives
and given hope to those
that most need it.
In December of 2004,
Ronaldo's number 7
was a symbol of hope.
An earthquake off the coast
of Indonesia
caused one of the most
catastrophic tsunamis
in recorded history.
A six-year-old Acehnese
boy named Maltunis
was swept out to sea
by the massive wave.
Maltunis was carried
into a mangrove swamp.
All he had to survive on
was rainwater in puddles,
and packets of dried noodles
that had washed up
in the wave.
He was alone like this for
19 days before he was rescued
and reunited with his father
and grandfather.
News agencies
broadcasted images of Maltunis
wearing a tattered
blood-stained,
red football jersey,
with the number seven.
The image of Maltunis
in that shirt went viral,
as did his story.
The young boy lost his mother
and sister in the tsunami.
Touched and heartbroken,
Ronaldo visited Maltunis
in Indonesia.
He paid for
the boy's education,
and made large donations
to rehabilitation
and reconstruction
efforts for the community.
Ronaldo also raised funds
for an improved mangrove
forestation,
a key element in helping
to save Maltunis' life
during the aftermath
of this heart-wrenching event.
♪
Ronaldo's critics
perhaps ignore
the star's many
philanthropic efforts.
When Ronaldo found out
his biggest fan
had life-threatening cancer,
his world
stopped spinning.
His mother was diagnosed
with breast cancer
and fought through a series
of debilitating radiation
treatments
to regain her health.
Having seen her suffer,
Cristiano generously donated
£100,000 to the hospital
that saved his mom's life.
He continues to support
charities related to cancer
and helped build a specialist
center at Hospital Central
in his native Madeira.
This past year,
Ronaldo received a letter
from the family of 10-year-old
Erik Cruz Ortiz.
The little Real Madrid
fan had a brain abnormality
that required surgery,
and the parents
were hoping Ronaldo would
donate a jersey
and some shoes
that they could auction off
to save money.
Ronaldo went
a few steps further.
He paid the £60,000
for the operation.
Massive inspiration to--
if you go back
home to Portugal,
I mean, the whole
of the country love him.
People don't know about
the philanthropic work
that he does.
A lot of his money goes
back into his home country.
He's massively involved
in the slums in Portugal.
He's been doing lots
and lots of work there
that people don't know about.
(narrator)
Despite all his fame and wealth,
no one can say that Ronaldo
is not a man of the people.
During Real Madrid's 3-1
victory over Chelsea
at the UEFA Champions
League friendly in Miami,
a fan raced onto the pitch
to give Ronaldo a hug.
(crowd cheering)
I remember
holding him, saying,
"Thank you, thank you,
thank you for this.
"Thank you for
all you've done for me.
"I wouldn't have been
where I am right now
if I hadn't followed
you as a role model."
I said, "I've always followed
you since 2005, 2006,
before you were even
famous in Madrid."
And I wish I had
the jersey, like I said,
to show him that
I wasn't lying.
It wasn't just for the fame,
I followed him for all,
since he was a teenager
just like me, what I am now.
When I knew he had
the potential.
So I said, "I followed you,
you helped me in life
"get through hard times because
I, just like you, Ronaldo,
"grew up with a single mom.
"I never grew up
without a dad, either,
I know what it was like."
And I think the moment
that really touched him,
I said, in his ear,
and I remember whispering,
not whispering, but telling
him in his ear, I said,
"If I ever, ever had a father
figure to help me in my life,
I always looked up to you
out of everyone in the world."
Because of everything
he's done.
His actions
on and off the soccer field.
(narrator)
Ronaldo graciously chatted
with the fan and walked
him off with security.
But the story
didn't end there.
Ronaldo wrote a letter
to the Florida judge
asking for all criminal
charges to be dropped.
I said to him, "Ronaldo,
you know, I followed
you and everything.
Please, you know, please,
don't let the cops take me."
And he said, "Don't worry,
I'm gonna take care of you."
(narrator)
In the letter, Ronaldo wrote,
"By all accounts he has
a bright future ahead of him,
"and I'd hate see
this future ruined
by an error of judgment."
The charges were
dropped the next day.
Cristiano is an athlete
who admittedly
takes a lot of pride
in the way he looks.
But after all, he does know
that it's all about branding.
Ronaldo opened a boutique called
CR7 in his native Madeira,
and another
in Lisbon in 2008.
Last year, Ronaldo designed
his own undergarment line
for men under the CR7 banner,
giving his critics
plenty of ammunition.
CR7 is the Cristiano
Ronaldo brand,
and I think it's
very significant.
I don't think it's as big
as Beckham, but then again,
Beckham is the number one
known footballer in the world.
Cristiano Ronaldo, I--
wasn't born into fashion,
let's be real, because
in the early days
when we saw him
with way too much hair gel,
I mean Dippity-do was
like his go-to.
It was just
to the extremes.
He's used very block, bold
colors, which is very much
Ronaldo's way of using
his fashion externally
as well as internally
on his underpants and socks.
To Beckham, there is no
comparison as footballers.
Looks, Beckham,
well in front.
Even though a lot of people
might have you think different.
(narrator)
He didn't care.
Profits experienced
a huge boost
as his brand continues
to grow in record numbers.
You have to be
in a situation where
you are a role model
for the children,
and so as long as they see
that that's what you are,
then these companies
that want to advertise you to,
well, advertise their brands,
then that's what they'll do.
And then, of course,
they're in a situation
where they can make
their own brand.
They can have their own brand
and sell that through.
And then
people will buy it.
The amount of money
that's poured into the game now
has risen
their status massively.
And that also obviously
will incorporate
that businesses will want
to be linked with them
and sponsorship deals on top
of that obviously
helps to increase
their income.
(narrator)
Following in the footsteps
of a former Man U player,
Cristiano was on the road
to becoming a legend.
You know, I've always
liked fashion, you know.
It's something that,
I like to look nice,
whether it be on the pitch
or whether it's, uh,
you know, out
having dinner with family.
(narrator)
Complete with a high-profile
girlfriend to match.
Irina Shayk.
When you're earning
the amounts of money
these guys are earning now,
especially Cristiano,
then what else does he probably
got to spend his money on?
(narrator)
The supermodel and Cristiano
have been
an item since 2010.
Another soccer icon,
Lionel Messi,
faces the similar
daunting task
of performing on the grand stage
of the World Cup.
FC Barcelona's Messi
is shorter
and without the marketable
good looks of Cristiano Ronaldo.
I just think
the way he plays the game
and the goals
he scores
and he just looks,
you know, spectacular.
A lot of kids,
probably because
of his physical
appearance as well,
would want to be Ronaldo
more than Messi.
Messi is a great player.
Everyone talks about
the Messi-Ronaldo.
Messi is a fantastic player,
but he's a great player in
a very good team, and I think
Ronaldo's an exceptional
player in a not so good side.
(narrator)
Ronaldo looks like
he was constructed
in a footballer factory
while Messi
is the everyman's player,
which is why many fans
gravitate to him.
These two often finish
one and two in most
of the Player
of the Year Awards,
and are constantly compared
with one another.
With Messi being
the build that he is,
he relies purely and simply
on his footballing ability.
And for that reason,
I give it to Messi.
I think you've got your obvious
Messis and your Ronaldos,
but what I quite want to see is
someone, not necessarily random,
but coming up
through the ranks
and maybe a Gonzalo Higuain
from Argentina.
You know, a star
player, but someone
who isn't necessarily
as well known as he
probably should be.
(narrator)
Ronaldo's transfer
to Real Madrid
only acerbated
the comparisons.
Messi would take home
the FIFA Ballon d'Or
for three straight years
before Ronaldo broke
his streak in 2013.
(cheering and applause)
(chattering)
(female translator)
Good evening.
There are no words
to describe this moment.
(cheering)
I want to thank
all my colleagues
and companions
at Real Madrid.
The Brazilian
and the Portuguese team,
and my family, who is here
with me today.
(translator)
It's a very important
prize and, like I said
in the press conference before,
I'm very happy to be amongst
the three best players.
For me it's a prize,
like I said,
Cristiano won it,
and he deserved to win.
(speaking foreign language)
(narrator)
Messi and Ronaldo
may be highly regarded
in the world of football,
yet on the international stage,
both come up short
in comparison
to the all-time greats.
Pelé won three World Cups,
the only player to do so.
Pelé is the, in my opinion,
the best player I've ever seen,
and I've got no reason
to change that.
So I put Pelé
in front of Ronaldo,
but Ronaldo in front
of Beckham, as players.
Looks-wise, I'd put
that reverse.
Beckham, Ronaldo, Pelé,
in the oil painting.
(narrator)
The other Ronaldo,
Ronaldo Luis Nazario de Lima,
won two World Cups
and is the leading
World Cup goal scorer
with an astonishing 15.
Diego Maradona
captained Argentina
to a World Cup victory
in 1986,
and Sir Bobby Charlton
became a legend
for helping England
to victory in 1966.
Bobby's one of the reasons
that I existed
as long as I did
in the early days
at Manchester United
because he believed in me.
He believed in the route,
the direction
that Manchester had taken
in terms of producing
our young players again.
And Bobby played an integral
part in that,
and I thank him
today for that.
(narrator)
This is the international stage
where football's elite
become legends.
With an audience
of over 700 million people
watching from all corners
of the globe,
it's on this stage
that the stars
of the game really shine.
World Cup defeats
have placed a lot of pressure
on this summer's
2014 campaign
for Ronaldo and Messi alike.
(translator)
Well, when the draw happened,
I was not watching.
I was actually sleeping.
I think I have to be
honest with you.
It's an extremely
difficult group with Germany,
who are always one of
the favorites for the title,
and the others,
the United States and Ghana,
who also have great teams.
That's why I think
it is a difficult group.
Portugal came
through the playoffs
after the qualification
for the World Cup,
so there's a good chance
that they could be
the dark horses
of the World Cup.
I think in that group,
Russia will be
more constant than has.
They play better,
and, um, we drop.
Not in a few
moments, points,
that you should don't--
don't lost.
But it's the past,
so we play the playoffs,
it was good for us.
We win both games,
we play very, very good.
(narrator)
But for Messi and Ronaldo
to establish themselves as two
of the game's all-time bests,
they will have to win.
Important-- all competitions
is important,
and this one is a special
one because it was in Brazil,
will be in Brazil.
For us, Portuguese country,
it's very important
because you know, we--
we have history with Brazil,
the culture, and...
And we speak
the same language.
So it's fantastic.
We are so proud
to be part of this big event.
I think Cristiano's chances
of becoming a legend
this World Cup
will unfortunately
not be solely determined
by him and him alone.
It will depend on how
the team as a whole performs.
If he can do that again,
then he will earn
that legend status.
And rightly so, if he could take
Portugal through to win
the World Cup.
Portuguese is
the same language,
we have a lot
of Portuguese there,
and we are very happy
for that.
And we, we try
to enjoy the,
you know, World Cup,
it's, uh,
the main competition
for national teams
so we try to enjoy.
(narrator)
In addition to any pressure
placed on the players,
the host country
had its own set
of issues to sort through.
Though Brazil was excited
about hosting the World Cup,
the cost of the event,
with the massive security
to not only protect the players
but the fans as well,
the stadium construction
costs well over $3 billion.
Regardless, countries
heavily vied for the chance
of becoming the host country.
England sent its own football
legend and a future king
to seal the deal,
but to no avail.
Even after winning the bid,
but years before
the actual event,
problems arise,
as in the case of Qatar.
However, with Pelé as the face
of Brazil's World Cup event,
this one is sure to become
an event for the record books.
(Pelé)
Was a surprise to everyone
what happened Brazil
because, uh,
this is
a political problem,
'cause I mention
about the--
the football
is the big promotion
of Brazilian country.
Then when you have
an event
like, uh, World Cup,
like Confederation Cup,
uh, you have Olympics,
you know,
then I think everybody
should be together.
But this is
a political problem.
We have that,
but no doubt, no doubt,
the World Cup
will be fantastic.
(narrator)
Love him or hate him,
you can't deny
that Ronaldo's impact
on the sport is immense.
He moves the needle.
Whether you're cheering
his every goal
or cursing his name,
he triggers a reaction.
He's one of the faces
of the game.
And that face will once again
be placed under the microscope
in Brazil, where the game's
best and brightest
will compete in front
of 700 million viewers.
In the World Cup,
questions are answered,
and the pressure to perform
is nothing short of daunting.
Once you reach
a World Cup, this...
you know, anything
can happen.
(narrator)
To play at the World Cup
is an honor,
and one that players
take incredibly seriously.
The pressure of playing for
your country is much greater
than playing for your club
for the simple reason
that you've got--
you're not only pleasing
one set of supporters,
you're trying to please
the whole, um, obviously,
the whole country.
And that, hence,
there's pressure with that
in that respect, and you've
also got the pressure
of trying to make people
understand and believe
that you should be there,
possibly in front
of their own favorite player
that plays for their club.
(screaming)
(chanting)
We deserve to win 100%.
Fast forward a couple of months
and we find Ronaldo
on the practice pitch
with his Real Madrid teammates.
His performance at the 2014
World Cup is now a distant
memory.
Fresh from winning
the UEFA Champions League Cup,
there were high hopes
for the Portuguese striker
as he scored 17 goals
in that tournament.
And that's not counting
the assists.
Well, it was an unbelievable
night to win "La Decima"
here in Portugal
with all this beautiful crowd
and it's something
that we're looking many,
many years of.
(man)
Cristiano Ronaldo does it again.
Every year,
I tried to do my best.
I score goals,
and I help the team.
(narrator)
He also took a lot
of punishment,
irritating a chronic injury.
An injury that would
follow him to Brazil.
Ronaldo's arrival was coupled
with both excitement
and speculation.
He was in great spirits
upon arriving.
But it was a different story
during practice sessions
in full view of the press.
We wanna win.
We can win.
We know it's gonna be difficult,
but I think we are
in good shape.
(narrator)
He played brilliantly during
team qualifiers,
but it was not the same
Ronaldo who took the pitch
against Germany
in Portugal's opening match.
And the look on Ronaldo's
face said it all.
With a 4-0 defeat
and a red card for Pepe,
Portugal's hopes for victory
were all but gone.
Obviously, it was
a difficult situation
to accept.
But there is body language
that many, many times
pushed the referees
to have these kind of decisions
and to leave a team playing
with ten men
for such a long time
is obviously a big handicap
for the team.
(narrator)
Ronaldo may have had
the game-changing assist
in the game against the USA.
(man)
Here's Cristiano Ronaldo,
oh it's a great cross!
and it is an equalizer!
(narrator)
But it was too late to change
the outcome.
USA and Germany would advance
and Ronaldo would
return back to Europe.
Now back with Real Madrid
and in better shape,
the old Ronaldo has truly
returned
as he scored both goals
in a UEFA game against Seville.
(man)
Gets it on to Benzema,
on it goes to Ronaldo.
Oh, yeah!
It was amazing.
A fantastic evening.
We win a very important trophy,
and I didn't play fantastic.
I scored two goals,
which in my opinion,
it was very important
for me to give me confidence
to start well the season.
So I'm good, I feel happy,
one trophy.
So very good.
(narrator)
However, even with this
promising outcome,
his injury came back
to haunt him.
Many say it's time for this
legendary footballer
to take a break.
If the injury persists,
Ronaldo's career in football
could come to an untimely end.
And there are other teams
that have Ronaldo
in their sights.
As Beckham builds momentum
for football in the US.
We don't want public funding. We
will fund the stadium ourselves,
create a stadium.
We wanna create a soccer team,
a football club
that is the people's
football club.
It's simple as that.
You know, I've worked
for some of the biggest clubs
in the world
with some of the greatest
players in the world,
and this is a dream.
If someone would have turned
around to me at 11 years old
and said, "You're gonna play
for Manchester United.
You're gonna represent England.
You're gonna play
for Real Madrid,
AC Milan, the Galaxy
and then become an owner,"
I probably wouldn't have
believed them.
(narrator)
Don't be surprised
if Ronaldo decides
to cross the Atlantic too.
- The girls love you.
- No, love you because maybe
I play good football.
Yeah, what about Galaxy?
Are you gonna join the Galaxy?
Yeah, you know,
- Beckham and Abel Xavier
played there.
- Yeah.
And I spoke with
him a few times.
He says it's great.
You should play here,
maybe in the future.
You never know.
He's such a talent.
He's such a great player
and a good person.
You know, he's one of the best
if not the best player
in the world.
So watching him is
a huge pleasure
for many Real Madrid fans.
(narrator)
Believe it or not,
this footballer may also have
his sights set
on a different sort of stage.
The silver screens of Hollywood.
(shouting)
And he always has time
for charity.
Proving that even
a freezing shower of ice
isn't enough to make him flinch.
Ronaldo accepted
the Ice Bucket Challenge
and lent his support
to the ALS Association
in order to raise money
for this worthy cause.
- (screams)
- (laughing)
Following in the footsteps
of some of the world's
biggest names,
ranging from director
Steven Spielberg.
Oh, man!
(narrator)
To David Beckham.
(laughing)
(narrator)
Even top fashion editor,
Anna Wintour of "Vogue."
(shrieking)
The idea is to have a freezing
bucket of ice water poured
on your head,
and bring attention
to a very worthy cause.
In America, the disease is known
as Lou Gehrig's Disease.
and in the UK
as motor neuron disease,
but the symptoms and effects
are the same
and devastating to sufferers
and their families.
- For the past two weeks...
- You have been reading
about the bad break I got.
- Yet today...
- Yet today I consider myself...
- I consider myself...
the luckiest man
on the face of the Earth.
(narrator)
It's of great importance
that people like Ronaldo
bring such a high volume
of attention to this disease.
As it is thought with the right
funding and the right direction,
this disease could be beaten.
Regardless of what
the future holds,
Ronaldo had made his mark
in history.
One of the best
if not the best player
in the world.
So for me it was
a fantastic year
and I win all
the individual awards.
(shouting)
(cheering)
This trophy is
for collective awards.
I'm really, really happy.
(narrator)
Whether it's a football pitch,
red carpet or magazine cover,
one thing is certain--
Ronaldo is here to stay
and he certainly has
the world at his feet.